oh non pour marc ancien policier et du
raid en direct avec tout donc sur rt
france monsieur pommard bienvenu merci
d'être avec nous en direct à leur
manifestation dans 80 villes
on vient de voir ces images le cortège à
paris est partie
pourquoi cette loi sécurité globale est
très loin de faire l'unanimité
écoutez très loin c'est ce que vous
dites mais je parce que au niveau des
forces de police en particulier de
gendarmerie et de tous ceux qui
travaillent pour la sécurité de notre
pays je pense que ces lois ne vont pas
aussi loin qu'au longtemps ces lois si
elles sont mises en place et si elles
sont décidées par le gouvernement
elles répondent à des problématiques de
sécurité évidentes dans notre pays on
l'a vu avec l'évolution de ces
manifestations depuis plus d'un an
maintenant
avec le départ des grandes
manifestations gilet jaune et on le voit
maintenant il est effectivement avec les
débordements que l'on connaît pendant
des manifestations
il faut que la police et les autorités
se donne toutes les possibilités de
pouvoir assurer la sécurité de ces
manifestations
et c'est vrai que d'écouter la la
sécurité globale mise en place par le
comédien la commission fauvergue de turo
à l'assemblée nationale est une
à mon avis une réponse idéale qui va
être réformé puisque vous l'avez vu vous
l'avez dit certains articles ont été
retoqués est apte à l'usagé des drogues
effectivement mais je pense que tous ses
moyens technologiques qui sont mises en
place matin sont utiles à la sécurité de
notre pays alors c'est une main pour un
protégé non forces de l'ordre comment on
en est arrivé là
écoutez une société qui évolue dans la
violence de plus en plus on l'a remarqué
on a une société si on déborde et des
manifestations on a qu'à voir ce qui se
passe dans le quartier autres où la
société de façon pas général mais pour
une partie sont de moins en moins
tolérante des règles de notre société du
respect de notre de notre de notre
société tout simplement et il faut que
encore une fois
ordre est la loi encore une fois et
malheureusement c'est l'escaladé je
dirais un terme pas de répression mais
surtout de moyens techniques qui
permettent à nos policiers et à nos
forces de l'ordre de pouvoir de pouvoir
répondre à cette à cette violence et on
le voit le sens espéré que cette
manifestation va bien se passer
aujourd'hui ces manifestations mais on
peut certainement ce qui est des
débordements
évitez tout ça je crois qu'il est
policier encore une fois au besoin de se
donner les moyens on l'a vu avec la
réforme du maintien de l'ordre qui a
évolué depuis les gilet jaune puisque on
avait pu on n'avait jamais eu affaire à
ce type de manifestation non un cadre
est ce un service d'ordre des hôtels et
policiers ont dû s'adapter
ça a été critiquée la police la
préfecture de police et le ministère de
l'intérieur on travailler sur ces sujets
là mais voilà encore une fois la police
évolué malgré ce que l'on peut dire pour
pouvoir répondre à la sécurité des
manifestations et de ceux qui viennent
manifester s'est manifestée par don
honorablement c'est à dire les gens qui
viennent
revendiquer les choses et et en même
temps comment dire pour les policiers
pouvoir gérer les violences qui sont
générées dans ses manifestations on le
voit avec les black blocks en
particulier alors en ce qui concerne en
tout cas l'article 24 qui va pénaliser
la diffusion malveillantes d'image de
policiers on a vu très récemment à quel
point l'utilisation de ces vidéos
pouvaient nous aider à y voir plus clair
et à comprendre ce qui s'est passé je
parle par exemple de débordements lors
de manifestations ou ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui des violences policières
permettez vols vont reprendre violences
policières pour moi c'est le câble
générique il existe pas encore une fois
en jette l'opprobre sur la police en
parlant de violences policières
les violences sont commises peut-être
par certains policiers
et ça jamais personne l'a remis en
question que ce soit le président la
république ou le premier ministre ou le
ministre l'intérieur et même les
syndicats de police lorsqu'il ya des
policiers qui sont différents et qui le
font pas leur travail de façon d autre
logique ils sont sanctionnés
donc je pense que ce côté systémique de
violences policières pour moi n'existe
pas je n'y crois pas j'ai passé trente
six ans dans la police et croyez moi je
connais bien cette institution et je la
côtoie encore faut d'accord bien sûr
alors comment on pourrait appeler ça si
on peut pas l'appeler violences
policières
mais tout simplement des fonctionnaires
qui se comporte pas de façon d auto
logique dans leur travail sont
sanctionnés sont réprimés par la loi par
les services de police qui existe chez
ea paix le pardon dit gpn qui est ainsi
service qui mérite d'être réformé où on
pourrait peut-être effectivement
accueillir des avocats ou des gens de la
société civile
c'est une chose mais sachez encore une
fois que
le ministère de l'intérieur sanctionner
les policiers malgré ce que disent
amnesty international ou la défense des
droits et tous ces gens là qui
effectivement cela pour s'opposer
évidemment à la loi à la règle je dirais
et surtout aux forces de l'ordre
cela évidemment pour jeter l'opprobre
sur sur la police nationale je pense que
très sincèrement pour connaître cette
maison encore une fois depuis très
longtemps que le mil riz gpn c'est un
travail important tous les ans pour
rappel il ya plus de 1500 policiers qui
sont sanctionnés pour certains même
révoqué donc on ne peut pas dire qu'il
n'y a pas de sanction envers les
policiers
mais accepter le terme de violences
policières c'est jeter l'opprobre sur
l'ensemble de la profession
alors va revenir sur l'article 24
puisque ces sujets qui me pose problème
en tout cas lors des manifestations ce
sera à mon juge d'interpréter s'il ya
intention malveillante 1 mais avant
cette interprétation il y aura eu
interpellations sur le terrain et là ce
sera un policier qui va la mener cette
interpellation donc sur son propre
jugement à lui c'est peut être ici que
cette loi pose problème écoutez moi je
pense que le film et c'est une bonne
chose en soi je vous rappelle d'ailleurs
que on va avoir la généralisation des
caméras piétons qui vont permettre de
d'abord de de désescalade et souvent les
interpellations qui se passe mal ça
c'est important d'éviter qu'en dirait
des violence d'un côté comme de l'autre
ça peut arriver donc ça va être une
question une bonne réponse et je crois
que il est important pour les policiers
de pouvoir filmer des interventions et
c'est dans les deux sens
lorsque je dis ça c'est autant pour le
contrevenant que pour le policier ça
permettra de voir que souvent
malheureusement les violences qu'elles
sont que verbale viennent souvent des
non pas des policiers mais de ceux qui
sont interpellés donc je pense que ça
donnera du crédit à nos policiers pour
leur intervention ça c'est une chose
concernant les manifestations je pense
que les policiers effectivement nous ne
doit pas être jeté en pâture et les
justes seront là pour effectivement
jugés c'est le cas de liens delà de
l'opportunité de sanctionner ou pas des
gens qui auront balancer en pâture les
policiers puisque non seulement c'est
pour leur intégrité morale et physique
des policiers mais également pour leurs
familles je vous rappelle que nombre de
policiers ont été jetés en pâture sur
les réseaux sociaux avec leur nom leur
prénom et leur adresse et je pense que
n'est pas possible d'accepter ça dans
une société d'un état de droit comme la
france
bonrepaux marc merci à vous d'avoir être
en direct sur rt france je rappelle que
vous êtes un ancien policier du renne
merci à vous